there's one thing you should know about  me I specialize in a very specific type  of security subconscious security you're  talking about dreams  mr. car has a job offer he would like to  discuss with you girl work placement  not exactly we create the world of the  dream we bring the subject into that  dream and they fill it with their  secrets  then you break it and still it well it's  not strictly speaking leaving  it's called inception already  I think I found a way home  and this last job that's how I get there  dreams feel real while we're in them  it's only when we wake up that we  realize something was actually strange  your responsibility you're not prepared  to this  drink scholastic  I have it under control  I need to see out of control we mustn't  be afraid to dream with a bigger darling